classic cars always turn heads
most people love to look at vintage
vehicles and a lucky few have the
pleasure of owning one
but even fewer drive theirs around every
day and draw plenty of envious glances
guy newmark from california is one of
those lucky people for close to half a
century he's been tooling around in this
1964 porsche
356c porsche
that
my family's owned almost since new
my dad got it uh
i guess
about
a month
after it was brought here to the united
states then he drove it for
three or four years
and gave it to me when i graduated from
college and we've been inseparable
everywhere i go i'm with blue
blue isn't just any old car it's guy
newmark's constant companion
blue has a
900 about 992 000 miles now
when i received blue it had a little
under 80 000. my dad had put that on it
76 or seven thousand and i put all the
rest on twenty thousand
miles a year that i put on the car
before taking over his father's yacht
business guy was his dad's right hand
man back in the days before email and
fax machines guy had to travel to his
customers to do business
sometimes he drove clear across the us
it was then that he developed his close
relationship with blue
and the car has held a special place in
his heart to this day
i love the color
the color is just magnificent it's bali
blue it's original porsche color we
haven't changed it at all
and
the other
thing is that when you're driving a 356
uh you're really driving a car
there's no special handling there's no
uh
you know gift of any mechanical you're
you're driving a car and when i talk to
people that have driven 356s and they've
sold them
every person 100 have said i'm really
sorry i sold my 356 because it's such an
exhilarating driving experience
since 1971 blue has shared the garage
with another porsche 356 a red 1962
convertible but blue remains guy's
favorite
so it's the original engine we've
rebuilt it twice
and matter of fact this last month we
just did valves and
went through the engine cad plated
everything we did rings new muffler and
blue's ready for another million miles
now
i think the secret is wonderful
engineering
and that combined with
proper maintenance
it is a mechanical item you do have to
maintain it and i'm pretty religious
about
changing the oil and taking care of it
and having the valves adjusted
another secret to blue's longevity is
the magnet affixed to the oil filter it
catches any metal particles that pass
through the filter and prevents them
from entering the engine compartment
guy also had the interior completely
refurbished although that was over 25
years ago
everything was restored to its original
condition
only the lamb's wool seat covers are the
owner's private touch
the old 356 c's odometer only goes up to
99
999 miles but guy plans to be driving
blue for a long while to come
blue's a buddy
i've been living with blue for almost 50
years so blue blue's a friend i talk to
blue all the time i just i'm in real
trouble if blue talks back to me
he loves the porsche but guy hasn't
always been faithful
well i bought another car
and i bought that car so i wouldn't have
to drive blue every day in case it was
raining or i just didn't want to drive
blue and the very first day i drove that
car on the freeway i was rear-ended and
pushed into the back of a truck and the
car was totaled
and i think it was blue saying what the
hell are you doing
and so i would drive blue every day
wherever i go no matter what the weather
is
blue's odometer shows that the porsche
has so far traveled 990
823 miles or around 1594
575 kilometers
that's the equivalent of rounding the
globe almost 40 times or traveling to
the moon and back twice
the car still has 9 000 miles to go to
crack the million mark but after 50
years on the road blue is still going
strong and shows no sign of slowing down